coqueluche hépatite b pneumocoque
méningocoque depuis l'an dernier les
nourrissons doivent donc subir pas moins
de onze vaccin avant d'être acceptés en
crèche ou en maternelle l'objectif fixé
par l'organisation mondiale de la santé
est d'arriver à 95 % de couverture
vaccinale pour beaucoup de médecins se
serait l'unique moyen de protéger
efficacement la population contre les
maladies infectieuses on peut mourir
d'hépatite b on peut mourir de rougeole
il ya eu des 40 aussi en métropole on
peut mourir de plan va pas mourir mais
être atteint d'une polio et avec des
séquelles qui sont quand même important
donc je pense que cette mesure est une
bonne mesure ce nouveau schéma vaccinal
vous avez moins d'injections parce que
les injections si elles sont faites plus
tôt
donc ce qui est préconisé par la
ministre de la santé
on a une amélioration de la couverture
vaccinale donc vous n'avez pas besoin de
faire plus de rappels lancés à grand
renfort de communication la mesure du
ministère de la santé vous l'êtes
enrayer le retour de maladie qui avait
pratiquement disparu comme la rougeole
la coqueluche ex inaction mais qu'en
pensent les principaux intéressés les
jeunes parents ça s'est très bien passé
et heureusement qu'ils allaient vaccin
parce que ceux qui n'ont pas le choix
dans certains pays
il tombe malade c'est une bonne chose
on est obligé de le faire mais quand
même faut quand même se renseigner pour
savoir à quoi sert ce qu'il ya dans le
vaccin que ma fille je demande chaque
vaccin nous savons ce qu'il ya dedans
quels sont les ifs et qu'est ce qui est
à prévoir après et c'est pourquoi ne pas
rester dans l'ancienne méthode douce
était étalée sur un certain nombre
d'années on les enfants le vivent très
bien donc sont trop d'un coup huîtres
massive ou des enfants aussi petit un
sentiment partagé par de nombreux
praticiens certains médecins sont
franchement contre et ont l'impression
de se retrouver aujourd'hui entre le
marteau et l'enclume
c'est une démarche qui sollicite
beaucoup au système immunitaire et qui
peut paraître sur certains individus à
risque
certainement ce d'autant que s'ajoutent
là dedans des quantités de d'aluminium
assez toxique en fait pour des cerveaux
tout jeune et on a des doses qui sont
supérieures aux doses maximales
vétérinaire et supérieures aux doses
toxiques pour un vaccin
donc c'est quand même à réfléchir monde
devrait avoir un regard un peu plus en
recul par rapport à cette
systématisation vaccinale autres
arguments des anti vaccin jusqu'à
présent aucune étude sérieuse n'aurait
clairement démontrer la véritable
efficacité de la vaccination obligatoire
le débat semble loin d'être clos